in the midst of a an opioid crisis where
people are dying every day
um you know it's a it's a staggering
number
you need to boil that ocean in about 15
minutes so we really decided
um consciously that this isn't going to
be
a pharmacy item if you put this on a peg
in aisle eight uh you know section six
of a pharmacy
it's gonna be a very slow adoption
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
if you're interested in technologies
that make an impact on the world
this episode is for you meet jason
sandby
ceo and chairman of verdi technologies
and partner of atlas capital partners
since 2015 jason has served as ceo of
verde environmental technologies inc
maker of the deterra drug deactivation
and disposal system
jason sundby welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i'm fine michael thank you i appreciate
the opportunity to speak with you
are you calling in from minnesota right
now
i am yeah suburb outside of minneapolis
yeah i love it i believe you're the
second guest i've had
from minnesota so i'm very very excited
for this conversation and jason there's
there's so many things that we can talk
about whether it's your 20 years
at star tribune a newspaper on on risk
management and i will have to ask soon
what
what does that entail the role of
director of risk management there
to regis corporation founding partner of
atlas capital partners but now
our conversation will also focus on
verde technologies and your product of
the terra
and talking about issues like the
prescript prescription drug abuse
environmental contamination so lots to
talk about at least 20 minutes
and before we get to to the the most
recent stuff
tell me a little bit about your your
career at a high level how
when you look back how do you see
yourself you know
running through your career you know
it's it's actually pretty interesting um
i started working at the star tribune
when i was
18 years old and uh i got a job in the
maintenance department to put myself
through college
and so i wiped up ink and oil and
picked up paper and cleaned bathrooms
from 10 at night till 6 30 in the
morning and so that's how i started i
you know i when i look back on my career
i basically put my
head down um decided that i was whatever
task i was given whatever job i was
getting i was
i was going to give my absolute all in
right and so i started out in the
position
uh and uh ended up leaving the star
tribune
as a director uh and so i i had moved
through the ranks a bit uh
from maintenance and um and then i was
was uh recruited and asked to join regis
corporation and i
i was uh i worked there and was promoted
there and stayed there for uh i think
10 12 years it was a good run wow uh and
then we formed atlas capital partners
which is a small private equity group
and
uh and then i was asked to take over
this role
with one of the portfolio companies wow
to become chairman ceo
i love it so if you show up like i said
i put my head down
i put my head down a long time ago and
and here i am today
you know um over 20 years at the star
tribune but i
you know i i want to stop it for short
pit stops before we get to
you know the really the most recent
advancement with verdi technologies
director of risk management at a
newspaper company what does that
actually mean
you know risk management can incorporate
an awful lot of things right but
whatever
whatever external even internal risks
but whatever external risks
are there you try to mitigate them
uh if you can't mitigate them you try
and uh
ensure against any catastrophic losses
um so that's
you know i mean it's it's anything that
can and will go wrong
uh you try and avoid it uh engineer it
out
uh or insure against it
and so when how does a day like that
look for you do you
just come to the office and think wow
what what could
destroy us today or what is happening
that might
lead to a problem down the line
yeah um i think i think basically you
become a
professional paranoid person uh in doing
that but you know what
you meet an awful lot of people you
learn every facet of the company
um because you're working with them to
understand
what what keeps them up at night and
then you try and
help alleviate that so you learn a very
broad base of business
uh and uh so that's that's what you do
amazing and so you're you're at atlas
capital you're a founding partner there
and then
i i didn't realize that you know verdi
technologies was one of your portfolio
companies that you decide to join
was that an obvious decision or is that
even a common decision
for a partner to join one of the
companies
right no so so our our um
investment thesis was to invest in
companies that are going to leave the
world a little better place than
we found it um but the founding partners
all had
uh long careers uh and different
experiences and so
part of what we did was not just invest
capital
but we invested um kind of human capital
our
expertise our experience um and as much
as these companies would have allow
um we would help them and uh so i was on
the board of directors of verde
technologies
uh and i was started by two very smart
chemists and a doctor of pharmacology
um but growing that business was not
their skill set uh and so i was asked by
the shareholders to step in and take
this leadership role
um i i i will tell you this
this late in my career i wasn't
expecting to work as
work as hard or as long as i i have
but it's extremely rewarding and we'll
get to that when we talk about our
mission but
um no it's not and it's certainly
nothing we set out to do
um certainly nothing i was
expecting um but when i was asked i you
know they answered the answer the call
so so let's head directly there very
technology is the mission the product
what
what is what do we have in store for us
right so i don't know if you've
seen our product and the good part is
i'm never far from it
but that's what it is so basically what
this product does
is it deactivates and destroys uh unused
and unwanted drugs
in your in your home um it's really
simple to use
uh it's a three-step process you open up
you had pills patches liquids
uh inside that pouch is a certain amount
in kind of activated carbon and a
water-soluble pod so think like a
dishwasher detergent pod
um you feel like with those drugs it
really works on a form factor and it
works on any organic compound
uh you fill it halfway full with warm
tap water that opens up that pod
and it dissolves and it pulls our
capsules uh you leave it open for about
20 seconds it's
carbon is extremely porous so you just
want the air to come out
uh you zip it closed but you got a
double zip device you shake it
a few times and throw it in the
household trash and through the process
of
adsorption the molecule of the drug is
bound onto the surface of the carbon
uh it renders it inert it's
irretrievable unrecoverable
uh at that point it won't leach into the
groundwater and so
it gets especially abusable drugs like
opioids which is a huge
problem in this country um opioid abuse
overdose and death
uh but there's also environmental
contamination of other drugs right so
endocrine disruptors uh
unused uh antibiotics from getting into
our lakes rivers and streams
we didn't really want to uh be working
so hard on two big societal problems by
throwing yet another plastic bag in the
trashy so this pouch
material is actually made out of sugar
cane
so a renewable crop it's made in a plant
that runs nothing but wind power
um it's i am green and usda certified
for those that know what those are
um but it's uh it's as green product as
we can make it
so um it's uh it's patented
13 u.s patents and 33 international pens
so it's a it's a good solid project and
our goal
is to prevent people from becoming
addicted overdosing and dying on opioids
and keeping these drugs out of our our
waterways
now you know why it's easy so tell me a
little bit about the scale
yeah i i can definitely see that you
know just like i
you know when i look at early stage
companies i i love
starting with the pain and you've
already touched on that i'm hearing two
things i'm hearing the
the prescriptive drug abuse specifically
opioids
which not only you know harms people but
can they can kill and lead to overdose
and you have a the environmental
as well which you're saying we don't
want the pills to just be part of our
water streams
by by having them go undergo this
chemical reaction you're actually
disposing them
in a safe way how big is this problem
what is the scale of this that we're
talking about is it you know a couple
households a lot of households
well the the problem i'll kind of
bifurcate this the the opioid problem
is big and getting bigger uh and
because of covid we had people go into
their homes stay in their homes
they may have lost their job or they
were very important about their future
and when that happens people are
stressed they self-medicate they tend to
self-medicate
and where do they look first they look
in their family medicine chest or a
friend's medicine chest
um so uh in 2019 72 000 people
in in the united states died from opioid
overdoses
four out of five people um that abuse
heroin or other drugs wow
um begin with opioid painkillers
that number rose uh i'm really sad to
see wow
it rose to over 90 000 this last year
and it very well may be in a rolling 12
month
uh over a hundred thousand people in
just this country
have died from opioid overdoses so um
so it's a it's a problem yeah it is
it is an unfortunate wow and on the
environmental piece
um there are over 150 different
pharmaceutical compounds found in our
lakes rivers streams
and our drinking water uh and they may
very well be at the micron level but
they are not intended for you
and there are a lot of articles saying
that those drugs um
you know after continuous ingestion of
them can cause
problems so that's that's what we're
working on
and uh and what we're trying to
accomplish so you know it sounds like
yeah it sounds like you know any of the
either of those two problems alone would
be something that
you know would provide for enough for
filming for a long long long long time
and i can only imagine working on those
two at the same time
how do so tell me a little bit about the
challenges of building a product like
this because you obviously have the chem
the chemistry aspect which i'm guessing
all the patents are about and and i'm
guessing that's solved
but now as the leader of this and you're
talking about you know consumer behavior
and you're talking about
you know the way people are are dealing
you know in in
situations of stress how do you actually
encourage people to use this
when even after they buy it
yeah you know i mean we do we do uh
marketing campaigns to get the word out
but you're you're very correct and and
here's our here's the conundrum right
so um it's a a new market
people have never really disposed of
their unused drugs in the past other
than
flushing them and putting them down sync
which is the environmental
environmentally bad part um so to get
consumer awareness
of a new category and a new product in
that category
it's kind of like trying to boil the
ocean well in the midst of a
an opioid crisis where people are dying
every day
um you know it's a it's a staggering
number
you need to boil that ocean in about 15
minutes so we really decided
um consciously that this isn't going to
be
a pharmacy item if you put this on a peg
in aisle eight uh you know section six
of a pharmacy
it's gonna be a very slow adoption so we
um we really kind of again split
our uh our efforts into foundational
working with the government
to get um you know the dea and the fda
to to either purchase or um
or endorse these products uh and then
the commercial side and we sell to
everyone from pharma manufacturers to
distributors
everybody along this continuum that
touches pharmaceuticals
to healthcare mayo clinic uh is a really
good customer of ours
uh you know we do sell in pharmacies uh
we sell to law enforcement we sell to
governmental agencies states and
attorneys general um so everyone that
touches it we've sold uh
enough product now to have uh
deactivated and destroyed over 700
million dosage units
pills if you will um
but our there are billions of these
opiates sitting in people's medicine
chests so we have a lot of work ahead of
us
and uh and we work very hard i i you
know i think one of the things when you
talk about my career i've always
prided myself on the fact that i hire uh
very very smart people
i surround myself with smart people and
then i think to my credit
i listen to them they uh they are
they are much more um you know a lot of
people don't do that but
you know what i i know when i'm out
outmanned and out
and these people are very smart and very
dedicated and we have a very good group
of people working
on this and what i always try to also
extract you know business lessons
both for myself as young entrepreneur
but i think they're just generally
interesting
you know why people decide what they do
and i think the really interesting
decision that you made here was saying
you know we we have our we have the the
science aspect the technology that we
created and then there's the
distribution
and at the end how do we actually
generate the most amount of impact and
and you're saying that you you you have
the option of going directly you know to
cvs in walgreens and placing
on aisle eight but you understand
already that the cons that you're trying
to boil an ocean
and and you're not going to be able to
do that as well and it's much better if
you focus on actual
the actual technology in the product and
you actually empower
governmental agencies law enforcement
dea fda et cetera
to actually go and and that's their job
really in the united states and and
other groups in the world right to
actually
facilitate this distribution and this
consumer awareness
and and i think that's just really
really interesting that's right
yeah and uh you know the way we look at
this we're a
small but growing company um and at some
point
uh will be a target for some very large
corporation um and they'll be able to
you know
turn this into a consumer product they
have the reach they have
the ability you know if you think of
some of these large uh
large companies that already have 30 or
40 products in a
in a pharmacy right um they can do that
um
our focus is really to try and de-risk
homes
um get these drugs out of people's homes
prove the concept in every one of these
market spaces
um and and garner a great deal of
shareholder value for this company and
then at some point
someone well and we've already had a
couple of overtures but
at some point some company will most
likely uh make a
bid for us right i mean it sounds also
that
you know you're taking it you're taking
a challenge you're saying we're gonna
shift consumer behavior it's not a
trivial
understanding of how how are consumers
gaining benefit
independently by using this product
right
you're actually asking them to take an
extra step out of their way
which w within with a you know
theoretical benefit
and so it makes it just that much harder
now there's it's undeniable
the the impact that this is going to
have on a skill especially as you're
telling me that dozens of thousands are
dying from this
and i can only imagine how much easier
it is for a large brand that has already
30 products
endorsing this and adding it as the 31st
product
that people should take with them as
they shop right
yeah absolutely you know that the um
there's another reason uh that that we
think that um
for us we need to focus on on those uh
folks that uh have skin in the game
pharma manufacturers and distributors
um and and that's where the money is
they that supply chain of
pharmaceuticals there's a lot of money
there
um all of our at home products uh
actually
are fairly inexpensive
our largest at-home product um is still
less than the cost of a latte at
starbucks
so and then it goes down from there so
five dollars or under
um but if you were prescribed an opioid
at the pharmacy
uh and you were um you paid
seven dollar copay and by the time um
people got this and if sold you know
wholesale for
three dollars by the time the
distributor and the pharmacy got their
money you'd be paying as much for that
uh as you would for the drug and you
might not have the foresight you're in
pain when you get opioids
and you might not have the foresight to
say i'm going to have some of these left
over and i'm going to get them out so
my kids or my family um and so that's
the other reason we really needed to go
after where the
the money was uh and uh and it's so far
it's worked quite well i mean we've
when when uh we kind of started this
rebranded in
2015 um we were in the uh
low six figures in revenues and now
we're in the
um eight figures or above
and uh and we're a private company so we
don't give away our revenue so it's
it's been good growth covid you know
pretty much plateaus for a year
um people weren't really releasing their
funds they were holding back
but we held our own and in fact we grew
our company
internally to be prepared for this
return as we come out of covid
and so far it's it's uh we're really
starting to see this uptake
jason it sounds exciting and it's
exciting to me to hear again
from another company that is really
really making a positive impact it's
undeniably a positive impact
a lot of companies like to say that
they're making that they're improving
the world of this you're actually
solving a problem that kills people and
then impact
billions of others drinking whatever
what i'm understanding
is not is not a clear clear water
jason i have a three more questions for
you they're not related to verde
technologies they're more about you
and the first one is what is your
favorite subject from middle school or
high school
you know i've i've always been a big fan
of history
and so i would say history class i had a
really engaging very intelligent
junior high school history teacher that
really you know
going to trip that trigger for me and
i've i i've always been a big believer
that
you learn a lot from history you take
the
good parts and build on them for the
future and you take the bad parts and
make sure they don't happen again
so that's my answer history is is the
that's my final answer
it's history
wonderful and who would be a role model
of yours or somebody that inspires you
uh you know i um i have two
uh one my father my father um taught me
you know right from wrong and taught me
a work ethic that has served me well
uh throughout these years and uh and the
other is john glenn
um john glenn was a us astronaut
and and what i took from john glenna he
was also a person of character he became
a u.s senator
um but if you persevere uh and you are
diligent you can accomplish anything
and i i always took that lesson from him
he's uh
he was a a great american and
as a as a young boy someone to look up
to
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i i think um
tenacious is one uh i'm
extremely inquisitive i like to learn
and i'm a lifelong learner um
and i thought hopefully it came across i
i like to think of myself as a friendly
person
i get along with most everyone it really
does
i love it jason thank you very very much
i really appreciate your time i know how
busy you are
thank you for all the work that you're
doing i look forward to coming back to
the us and
and and purchasing these and using these
myself so thank you for sharing that
with me
and uh stay safe thank you michael i
appreciate the time
take care
[Music]
you